[Music]
building new offices in the center of
London costs more than anywhere else in
the world construction of a normal
office costs roughly 1/5 more than in
New York or Hong Kong leasing office
base in the West End costs roughly
double what it does on Madison Avenue
why is London so expensive foundations
first London's are littered with tube
tunnels government tunnels sewers and
oddities like the Royal Mail railway
running under Oxford Street unexploded
bombs dropped by the Luftwaffe still
turn up surprisingly often Bloomberg's
new headquarters in the city was delayed
by the discovery of around 10,000 Roman
artifacts above ground narrow streets
make getting vehicles and machinery and
very expensive on some construction
sites space is so tight that cranes a
custom built the city's medieval Street
pattern means that few buildings can
have clean 90-degree corners
necessitating expensive design the
planning system then adds all sorts of
expensive complexities in Westminster
over three-quarters of land is covered
by 56 conservation areas protecting the
historic appearances of streets right
down to the color of their doors in the
City of London protected views distort
the skyscrapers the curious shape of the
Leadenhall building known as the cheese
grater is intended to protect a view of
sin Paul's Cathedral from a pub on Fleet
Street
London's success continues regardless
firms are keen enough to be in the city
that they will pay sky-high rents for
the privilege that gives developers the
incentive to get over the many hurdles
London puts in their way The Economist